hey guys it's Tuesday and thanks for
choosing to tune into games what news
wow that's annoying sorry to set you up
with some bad news but it turns out that
via shoot either we saw from Final
Fantasy 15 won't be coming out after all
originally revealed last year the game
cost us Prompto in a light gun type game
as you pute a bunch of targets
unfortunately though you'll have to
settle for cosplay and finger guns a
Square Enix table GameSpot in a
statement today Final Fantasy 15 VR
experience at e3 2016 was a technology
demo that we showcased since then we
have learned much from the technology
and have leveraged our learnings from
the episode Prompto dlc the result of
that is our first PlayStation VR title
monster of the deep final fantasy 15 so
it's not all bad monster of the deep
Ward's revealed at e3 this year and will
allow you to go fishing with your Final
Fantasy Bros via the magic of
PlayStation VR while the original VR
title was intended to be free DLC for
those that own Final Fantasy 15 monster
of the deep will be a standalone title
you may remember last year when Blizzard
decided to change the name of its client
battlenet to the Blizzard app well
they've changed their mind again hey
just like my ex-wife choosing a
restaurant ayoh story going forward you
can refer to the blizzard app as
Blizzard battlenet best of both worlds
the thing is as any PC gamer can tell
you we've been saying battlenet for way
too long for to just be replaced by a
whole other thing was it said in a blog
post battlenet is the central nervous
system for Blizzard games and the
connective tissue that has brought
Blizzard players together since 1996 the
technology was never going away but
after giving the branding change further
consideration and also hearing your
feedback we're in agreement that the
name should stay as well take it from
the developer formerly known as silicon
& synapse and chaos studios names are
important to staying with the theme of
changing names h1z1 just survived the
zombie MMO it's changing its name and
adding new content as part of a new
update the update which is out now
introduces a new map completely rebuilt
weapons strongholds and new currency and
a new stuffy title h1z1 just survived
will now be known as just survive not
survive just survive as
it's just just survive now publisher
daybreak made the change as to separate
the title from the h1z1 universe the new
map bad water Canyon will replace the
game's original map and has been
designed with multiple styles of
gameplay in mind the map will also focus
on a new stronghold feature that allows
players to build robust structures and
fortify them with an array of Defense's
and traps to fend off coordinated
attacks you'll be able to buy stronghold
locations with the new golden eagle
coins which you can acquire by trading
in valuable items just survive is still
in early access on Steam along with its
counterpart king of the kill which will
eventually make its way to consult at
some point if you're interested in all
the nitty-gritty details of this update
you can head on over to GameSpot for the
full list that is everything we've got
for you today to let us know what you
thought of today's episode and today's
story will be done in that comment
section if you want to say hi and we'll
see you again same time tomorrow silicon
& synapse no synapses and Stinnett and
silicon instant nap say Obama Obama
Obama an abominable